revenons à présent aux origines de la
musique la musique vraiment classique
cette fois ci avec vous célia bizet
debussy ravel les plus grands noms on
résister dans ce département oui ils
sont nombreux l'âge d'or se situer entre
1850 et 1940 et je propose que l'on
commence par un extrait écouter
[Musique]
alors oui je dis que ce qui gêne t mais
moi je triche et les éléments
oui c'est le boléro de ravel c'est ça
c'était air cultissime a été composé
dans les yvelines à montfort l'amaury en
928 1928 brabus est déjà révisé
il avait acquérir une maison en 1921 a
surnommé le belvédère il va y habiter
pendant 16 ans et qu'on posera aussi ces
deux grands dernier un chef-d'oeuvre le
concerto pour la main gauche et le
concerto en sol la demeure est devenu
maintenant un musée dédié à l'artiste
alors il ya une ville un peu
emblématique justement de cette musique
classique c'est bougival oui cette
commune située sur la rive gauche de la
seine a vu naître de grands noms a vu
que je disais qui a composé carmen don
carmen est né à bougival la célèbre
sévillanes et l'aîné à bougival l'opéra
le plus populaire au monde le plus joué
au monde et le plus traduit au monde et
donc voici l'ère on peut écouter
très connue
alors à la même époque pauline viardot
cantatrice et pianiste et qu'on peut
être compositrice recevait dans son
salon toute l'élite musicale elle
posséder une villégiature à bougival
autres compositeurs célèbres alors à
vous de le retrouver avec cet ouvrage
comment attendre alors indices il est né
à saint germain en laye ça change tout
si vous dites saint germain en laye
forcément c'est depuis 6 gb/s personne
ne m'a vu baisser les yeux à seulement
là sur mes notes c'est exact donc c'est
le clair de lune bien sûr aussi très
célèbre alors lui donner en 1900 1862 en
sa maison une attelle est devenue elle
aussi un musée alors les îles ils sont
en fait eux considérés par les éthiques
les artistes comme une terre de nature
et invitant à la création artistique
à l'époque les réseaux de chemins de fer
aussi se sont installés à rueil
malmaison et ont attiré beaucoup de
parisiens et donc beaucoup d'artistes
dans l'ouest parisien
voilà que reste-t-il de cet héritage
justement eh bien il reste pas mal
encore d'artistes un de compositeur et
de musiciens philippe jaroussky par
exemple le contre-ténor est l'un des
grands noms du paysage musical actuel le
futur centre européen de musique qui
sera lui aussi basé à bougival veut
former les musiciens des deux mains et
après il ya eu les coïncidences avec les
réseaux de chemin de fer qui sont
installés très vite vers rueil malmaison
donc à partir de là les lieux de
villégiature
avec aussi par exemple à bougival l
implantation du célèbre bal des
canotiers attiré beaucoup de parisiens
se sont dans des musiciens diplômés de
l'école de musique de conservatoire et
d'académie d'europe qui vont avoir un
parcours de deux ans pour les aider à
rentrer dans la vie professionnelle
les jeunes générations peuvent donc elle
aussi un espérer une renommée mondiale
et ainsi participé à la renommée des
yvelines comme terreau musical merci
célia